let's continue our conversation with dr.
Peter Bogosian Peter an issue that I'm
very interested in because I think that
it is very often portrayed in accurately
on the political spectrum by both sides
is that issue of what is often called
white privilege now you've written about
white privilege for our conversation I
want to restrict our conversation to the
United States specifically and I think
it will sort of become relevant why as
we go on do yoga leaders that in the
United States in 2017 there is any
degree of what is colloquially referred
to as white privilege yet can I ask what
you mean by that because we may mean
different things by that I guess by
white privilege I mean an unearned
deference that one has by virtue of
being or being perceived as and the
perceived as will be relevant to our
conversation in a majority white country
by virtue of being perceived as white do
I think that that confers social or
confers advantages on people short yeah
I do
so talk a little bit about where you see
white privilege as a real thing and
where you think that some assertions
about white privilege sort of go off the
rails well this is a huge conversation
15 how long do we well it's fine I mean
I think let's consider it an overview
conversation something we might dig into
in more detail at some future point so
is it more or less so this is an
empirical question to which I do not
have the data it's outside my area of
expertise but this is a way that one
would think about the problem is it more
or less likely that somebody who's black
or perceived as black would be pulled
over by the police for a minor
infraction in a vehicle than somebody
who's white or perceived as white my my
hunch would be to say yes although I
watched a Larry elder at D Reuben video
that really made me think that my belief
in this could be
might not be as evidence-based as it is
and I have to say I don't have the
evidence but I do have what I think of
good ways to think about the problem so
and then what are the what are the
consequences of that what are the
consequences for the criminal justice
system I mean we know by and large that
the criminal justice system is geared
toward money so if you're wealthy you
have more opportunities to get off even
if you're guilty frankly then than if
you're not and we know that that poverty
is I wouldn't say endemic in the black
community but I would certainly say
statistically there are larger numbers
of african-americans living in poverty
in our percentage of whites so I do
think that white privilege is something
that's real it may correspond to
economics
it may also correspond to the fact that
black on black crimes are perceived as
so again that the whole issue is just so
charged that we have we have really
created a I noticed that I'm being far
more judicious in my words because I
know that any misstatement or anything
that I can say will be perceived as
something else I don't think we're ready
to have an honest conversation about
this I think enjoyed an offer I mean
just a bit like an anecdote you know I
feel like I have white privilege despite
being unclear as to as to whether I'm
white and what I mean by that is I'm a
Hispanic immigrant to the United States
or whose ethnicity I'm from Argentina my
ethnicity is ash can assi Jewish right
and I am sort of and I use the term
lucky maybe it's not the exact right
term but I have benefited from the
reality that I moved to the US when I
was five instead of ten and thus lost my
accent when speaking English and because
my ancestry ethnically is European
Ashkenazi Jewish I also am perceived as
white now social class being the same
education of the invision like excuse me
visually perceived his wife visual
perceived as what yeah so holding my
social class level and sort of my
education level the same as it is I am
very aware that when I have an
interaction with police my ability to
say what I think is concerning about
their behavior if I see them harassing
someone on the street or when they show
up at a loud wedding party that I'm at
like I was at last week if I had darker
skin and had learned English five years
later and thus had an accent my
intelligence would be the same my social
class you know holding everything else
equal my relationship with the police
might be different my comfort level in
being sarcastic or indifferent would be
different so I think that this is sort
of an interesting idea that I've lived
myself you know yeah I think everything
you said well I don't have any evidence
for I don't have faith in it I think
it's probably true
nothing is probably true look if if I
may interject something else this is
kind of a secret I don't want anybody to
know but it's a good reveal on your show
if you think have been white privilege
of something waiting to get to be my age
then you actually see it I mean you know
gray hair older guy privilege is awesome
interesting and again I mean people
everybody it seems like just yesterday
I'd walk into a store when I was a
teenager and people think I'm gonna
steal stuff and a little while I was in
store and someone said Oh sir I need to
leave can you watch the store for me
what uh but yeah even when you go
somewhere you know like I go and I don't
have my ID on me and I need to go to a
bar a few drinks and I just point to my
head below okay um but I have definitely
felt old age or older age I don't think
I'm old age yet but I definitely felt
middle-aged privileged among the police
people calling everybody calls me sir so
I think that there are definitely you
can extrapolate outward from that and
you can listen to the sincere testimony
or or when people say look you know I
don't feel comfortable and it's not just
the police I think it's a general
attitude I think that police have an
extremely difficult job and they're
caught between some bad laws like some
drug laws and enforcing those laws and
they're caught between the the fad this
is when we get
this is when the conversation gets very
tricky but now and not tricky in terms
of facts but just tricky in terms of the
political implications that one draws
from those facts I think that the if you
look at the majority of you just need to
look at the majority of crimes
specifically violent crimes and murders
and I think that that and again I don't
have access to those to these data and
I'm happy to change my mind but it is my
impression that a black man is far more
likely to be killed by another black man
then a white man is to be killed by a
black man well that on that that's true
but where that often goes off the rails
is that if you are white you're
basically just as likely to be the
victim of another white person a
grieving you then ever you are black and
you know it's basically interracial
violence is what happening but just
because there are more wipes that's just
a statistical thing well there's more
White's who could be victims and more
whites who could be perpetrators in the
same way right i mean it's proportional
well if you look at the number of
homicides and again i'm getting out of
my area now so i'm a little little
articles about speaking about this stuff
but if you look at the number of
homicides and here's how we know that of
black people who have been killed by
other black people and then we look at
we max those two the incarceration rates
of black people and said well how do you
know it wasn't someone else's because we
get that from the eyewitness testimony
of people who perceive other people's
races a certain way could say well that
testimony is biased okay maybe it is I
don't really know I'm not an expert on
witness testimony but I think it's very
difficult for the police because they're
trying to do the job and I think we have
to ascribe excuse me good motivations to
the overwhelming majority of police
officers they're trying to do an
incredibly difficult job and save
people's lives and they're confronted by
some pretty ghastly statistics that
accord with their own personal
experiences and look this is what I
think we should do you want to know
here's what I things to do yeah
and here's what I think what I think we
should do will absolutely never in a
million years happen and this will tell
you how toxic our current environment is
we need to have expert
it's on and I am NOT one of these people
by any stretch of imagination we need to
have experts on
policing the rules of policing and
public policy and when force is used in
one and we need to have those people
have a discussion maybe even debate if
you want with giveme activists in the
community i black lives matter I
wouldn't say so but and we need to have
that conversation at a university and we
need to have a civil conversation and we
need to really see for your gun harbor
must calls mutual understanding could
you fathom that happening
they'll be practically speaking pretty
difficult yeah I mean it would not wake
up no it would not even be deferred it
would not it would be you could never
have that conversation so we I think I
can do it I think I could moderate that
and have some degree of success if we
had the right people in the room I would
love for you to treat you do this I'll
fly out to be CEO teach ABC you say look
I would love to see the administrators
face when you tell them I I think that
we should have a that I would like to
moderate a conversation between people
now get actual policemen not people
who're professors who theorize about the
police get people who are actually
involved in these decisions and it can
explain to people and then get people on
the other side of the room try to bring
them together have a civil conversation
I don't think any administrator will
approve it because I don't think we're
ready to have those conversations I
think that people are afraid that
violence will erupt and I think there's
a good reason people are afraid that
violence will erupt but that's the kind
of conversation we need we need to have
mutual understanding to seek mutual
understanding between members of the
community and members of the police for
example why should you when the police
and even I do this because my gray hair
privilege when that when the police pull
you over why should you keep your hands
on the steering wheel well you should
keep your hands on the steering wheel
because there have been many instances
and I've seen them I've seen these
videos myself where people then pull
guns out and shoot the cops so we need
to look at this issue from both sides
and I don't think it's simply as easy as
systemic racism I think that the police
have an incredibly difficult job to do
but to get back to your earlier point I
do think there's white privilege I do
think that there's value and meaning and
talking about that and I do think that
if we're honest about that and we can
communicate about that then we can gut
healing is a goofy word but it really is
the word that applies we can try to heal
these deep divisions one more thing we
can do that by appealing to super what's
called in the literature super identity
so super entities we're all Americans
remember right after 9/11 from the
others time everybody was super civil
and you want to get into traffic people
let you go that lasted about ten days
maybe two weeks tops but we can appeal
to commonalities that we have so that we
can solve these problems that's why the
most important thing that we can do is
to have a conversation and David you
would be that really you really would be
among the most perfect people to attempt
to broker that conversation if you could
do that you would really have something
extraordinary on your hands well I can't
think of a better place to take our last
break than that we will wrap up with dr.
Peter Boghossian next